[Music]
war the universal language
I know renegade so to her see never
occurred to me that one might come from
above
space invasion
big car chase
truth be told I was ready to hang it up
to let miss you today so you're not from
around here it's hard to explain
I keep having these memories
I see flashes
[Music]
I think I had a life here
but I can't tell if it's real
we have no idea what threats are out
there
we can't do this alone
we need you
I'm not what you think I am
hey everybody we got to break down this
Captain Marvel footage if you're new to
the channel there's a new round of that
spider-man ps4 giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video most of you have
probably noticed that the energy that
crackles off of her at the end of the
trailer when she's in her classic red
and blue gold comic book costume looks
amazingly similar to the quantum energy
that ant-man was collecting at the end
of ant-man the wasp there's also that
voiceover that samuel l.jackson is young
Nick Fury has during the trailer where
he talks about how they need her so
that's obviously a reference to Avengers
4 stuff but obviously that's coming
within the context of this secret
invasion storyline that they're trying
to solve there's a couple funny Easter
eggs you guys probably noticed
Blockbuster Video is probably the best
way to open that trailer so there are a
couple of different storylines that they
cut up across the trailer itself you
have her time with Star Force on the
Kree homeworld and then going on a
rescue mission then you have her coming
back to earth then you have all of her
origin stuff and her getting her powers
that's probably what this scene is right
here so let's just go through this shop
by shot there's a whole bunch of stuff
but like I said there's you know three
really big storylines Star Force the
origin story then her on earth and
present-day punching old lady's on Los
Angeles Transit this is gonna be a great
moment to like oh sweet little old lady
just clocker
right in the face because she is
probably a scroll that first shot of her
falling to earth in the green star Force
uniform that's in present-day because it
looks like she runs around Los Angeles
which is where the movie largely takes
place on planet earth with her running
around shooting up Skrulls looking for
people that she's in this train depot
that's part of the big train chase scene
where you see her jump on in the
platform here she's just trying to find
these scrolls that you see land on the
beach but then you see that they
actually do Captain Marvel Mohawk when
she's in the Star Force mission you see
her in the Nine Inch Nails t-shirt with
the shield hat on this looks like the
proto version of project Phoenix the
Avengers base that we see at the
beginning of that movie before they blow
it up it was built during the early 90s
now I didn't spot any actual dates in
the trailer but we will probably see
something on a newspaper or something
that'll help us pinpoint exactly which
year it is when this picks up Nick Fury
has the voice over saying that he's of
getting a little bit older he's thinking
about
hanging his badge up he's thinking about
retiring makes a couple jokes about
alien invasion then you see them
dissecting one which i think is a sort
of reference to area 51 within the
context of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and if you couldn't tell from this
picture that person standing with them
is Coulson this is what he looks like
young Coulson we've seen all the
pictures of young Nick Fury but we
haven't seen young Coulson yet I've
already talked a little bit about his
version of the character in this movie
he's a fresh agent Nick Fury isn't super
hot on him he's obsessed with MC Hammer
so they're gonna use him for a little
bit of comedy a little bit of action
towards the end of the film
Coulson always gets to do something
really silly but really badass by the
end of the movie Nick Fury whips his
shades off that's just meant to be the
two eyes reveal like oh my god Nick Fury
has both eyes and he has some hair on
his head she starts to narrate her
origin story when he says you're not
from around here she jokes that it's
complicated which is true because her
comic book origin story is very
complicated but they jump to the Kree
homeworld you get a couple more star for
shots that's their spaceship here you
see her looking out on this scape here
this is one of the main cities on the
Kree homeworld I don't think that we've
ever actually been on their home planet
before so it's actually pretty cool then
they start giving you the flashes of her
origin story when she was an Air Force
pilot she says that she has memories of
a life once on this planet so you have
to imagine that she's been part of Star
Force for a while and her experience has
sort of messed with her memories a
little bit I've already talked a little
bit about Maria Rambo she's the mother
of Monica Rambeau so she might be a
character in present-day in a future
Marvel phase four or phase five movie it
just seems like they intend on doing
that at some point you get more
flashbacks cut up - when she was a
little girl just sort of showing her
life
all the way up to her accident this
footage of her here when she's in the
Air Force pilots uniform and this giant
explosion seems like when she gets her
powers so even though they said they
aren't doing a traditional origin story
movie we will get to see a version of
her origin story so like her skin starts
to crackle with energy it just seems
like she's testing out this jet goes
into orbit sees this alien spacecraft
they both crash on planet Earth then the
Kree ship blows up and that's what
infuses her with all this energy this
scene with her upside down in the
harness seems like it's coming from
later when she's part of Star Force on
that mission early in the
film he had a much better shot of Jude
Law remember he's a pink skin Cree they
still haven't confirmed him as Marvel
but it seems like he really is playing
that original Captain Marvel and sort of
teaches her about her powers you get the
scene of her punch in the old lady who's
probably a scroll there's a big fight on
an alien battlefield that might also be
from the Star Force mission earlier in
the trailer when she has the mohawk and
they're all flying into battle there's a
shot of Ronan in Earth's orbit which
could be from later in the film closer
to present-day because I've talked a
little bit about the original Kree
scroll war and how Ronan was involved
with that he's been to Planet Earth many
times as a villain and as a friend to
the Avengers so it gets kind of
confusing well to wait for more footage
of him Nick Fury whips out his pager it
looks like he's trying to communicate
with her with the target so that's
probably talking about the Secret
Invasion scroll stuff that's happening
later in the film but obviously a bit of
a wink at the souped up space pager at
the end of Infinity war that he used to
call her back to Planet Earth the energy
of the explosion that gives her her
powers looks really blue but the
interesting thing is though is that when
you see her power up at the end of the
trailer it looks much more like the
quantum energy that we see from the
quantum realm post-credit scene an
ant-man in the wasp you get a much
better shot of her in the helmet that
actually looks really badass I was
really hoping that they would find a way
to incorporate a couple different
versions of the costume even if it was
only briefly just a week at the comics
but they did the Mohawk they did the
helmet it doesn't look silly it looks
really cool so I'm really happy with the
visual style of the film and I almost
forgot to mention too when she crashed
lands in the blockbuster there's a bit
of a funny wink at the camera she stands
up and in the same frame there's a
little sign that says action pointing
down at her it's just a funny wink at
this being Marvel's first big 90s action
style movie so like Terminator 2 the die
hard movie just imagine them doing
something in the tone of those style of
movies but everybody let me know what
you think of her costume the way that
they're visualizing her powers and the
way that they're cutting this movie up
giving you the flashbacks to her origin
story what'll probably happen is now is
that we'll get that Avengers 4 title
before the end of the year Kevin Feige
said that they would start promoting
Avengers 4 towards the end of the year
so that could be the end of November
that could be December so just keep that
in the back of your mind it's not gonna
happen tomorrow I don't
think I think they're gonna let this
settle for a little while but what'll
happen is is I'll do more Captain Marvel
videos this week leave your requests in
the comments below
but I'll name a new giveaway winner when
I post new Marvel click here for brand
new venom and click here for brand new
Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]